ni
Let's write about a public bath in your neighborhood in Japan and walk around It's easy to think that it has a slightly old-fashioned atmosphere like a movie,
but it's a harbor retro after going around.
I wonder if new needs are emerging in such a place.
I'm
Mizuki Tanaka. I'm changing the paint a in battle. Me Is battle a
flowman that everyone can enter in Japan?
But in the
old days, that
It seems that there was a custom of behaving religiously
, and from there the culture of becoming a professional has taken root, and
when the economy of the battle is good, a very luxurious temple-like building is built.  And since
that kind of cherry blossom culture is rooted in it,
I enjoy the fact that there are escorts and that some nice tiles are treated like
this. In
the style of St.'s paint painting, it's a landscape.  I write a picture and write an uncle that it is the most but large. There are many
colors like a
blue sky and a blue Mt. Fuji and a white group, a waterside landscape with a green mountain in a distant mountain
.  However,
[music]
I wonder what the role of paint painting in a public bath is. The
feeling of traveling to various areas while in Unataka is like getting a suicide note
and the joy of coming into contact with a new world through repetition.  So
I think it's quite important that you enjoy looking at it vaguely and feel positive
again.
I wonder if this is the case because it has become a relatively unusual pattern in Japan to come as a craftsman, such as how it has decreased since the 1970s
.
But today
, I'm listening to the guests.
I think
it's possible for various people to see the actual writing of the pen type at events, such as using the internet to provide information.
I wonder if this is a challenge, but
yeah, the
reason why I'm continuing this work is that it's fun to
write.
Something like that joy
[music]